but when you say mental breakdown what
happens when you have a mental break cuz
I cuz I I feel like I've had one as well
and I had to go and get
myself you know I just went through a
really tough time and a lot of people
out there do a lot of people every I
feel like every great actor should have
one
um um because it really changed
everything uh I got married so B
basically what happened was my show
ended numbers ended I didn't know who I
was anymore I didn't know what my career
was I got married and the very next day
I flipped the [__] I flipped out we
made the mistake I made the mistake we
booked uh our honeymoon the next morning
in St Barts beautiful place except we
went during the off seon so everything
was closed and when we got there uh uh
the the island had just had like a
massive storm so the internet and TV was
knocked out so here I come from like the
most wild rockus night of my life in
this huge momentous occasion and I find
myself in an island in the middle of
nowhere where all the stores are closed
all the restaurants are closed the only
food I can get is at the hotel there's
no one at the hotel [__] place is
empty and I got like Island fever and
that's how the nervous breakdown sort of
start started so my so three three and a
half days in I said to my wife I said we
got to get out of here and we had booked
an eight day
honeymoon and we left we left my much to
her parents sugrin you know my in-laws
were like what the [__] is going on I
was like I'm I'm freaking out I'm
freaking out I can't stop panicking I
can't I have bad anxiety I cannot stop
panicking the anxiety then turned into
really deep
paralyzing
depression I I became a gorap phobic I
couldn't leave the house and it went on
for nine months it was a full nine
months right after you get
married and right after my show ends
which was a big successful show yeah so
my my wife God bless her was just like
who is this person and you tricked me
you basically you tricked me we're
married now and you're a mess how did
this happen and I felt terrible I felt
so bad you know and it made things worse
you know that I had to face her and I
was scared of her I was like scared of
her coming home because I didn't want to
be a burden on her um it was really
really intense really intense time um
and I got sober during it I got you know
I tried everything I could you know I I
wasn't into getting on meds but then I
sort of sort of you know you know just
put I just realized I was powerless over
what was happening and again it was all
happening mostly because my thyroid
wasn't working but I didn't know that um
but yeah I I became a total reck loose
shut in nervous mess ball of depression
like scary depression deep deep deep
depression for nine months did she did
you think she was going to leave
you no uh no really what made you feel
that way that she wasn't going to leave
me
yeah um she's the most wonderful person
on Earth and I
knew and and she was my motivation to
get better you know if I was alone or
whatever single dude I would have Pro
maybe even offed myself to be honest
with you you were that bad oh it was bad
it was really really bad I lost my mind
you know you lose your mind you know you
you just you lose it